How often should a person do new blood work?
Well, that's completely dependent upon what's going on with the person's treatment plan
and what's going on with previous blood work.
So if you've had previous blood work that has been abnormal, then you should do it more
frequently.
Also, it depends on the person's current state of health.
Let's say you're currently feeling great, but you had some abnormalities, let's say,
and your liver enzymes were slightly elevated.
How often should you do new blood work?
Well, then you factor in other things.
Well, I'm not doing chemotherapy, which can greatly affect my liver enzymes.
I'm not doing fenbenazole or hymerrectin that can greatly affect your liver enzymes and
that past trend was just a slight slow elevation of those liver enzymes.
Well, maybe you're going to wait a month, depending on the trend, the previous trend
if you were doing it monthly, maybe you're going to wait two months, maybe you're going
to wait three months, but it depends on all these different factors.
So if your current state of health is good and your last blood work was good, you were
doing it, let's say every three months and it would spend normal, normal, normal, normal,
and you're still doing well, maybe you could wait six months, it's everybody's different.
So if you're going to assess that as an individual.